wait a minute why are the mariners and
grace the a's and whites if i don't know
anyway justin dunn
is making the start in this nightcap
he has made nine starts on the season
this will be that would hit high and
deep toward the right field corner lopes
in front of the wall leaps and that baby
is gone
so grossman with a first inning home run
and the eas lead one nothing go to
mariner stat count for more details 2-1
pitch
up the middle there's the first hit
[Applause]
good for d
so one out base runner
bring up the catcher joseph odom
get a base hit here d
ready to run
pitch up high
and stop by orf throw over off the bag
dee will hold at third
jp
drives it the other way a long distance
look at this
dee's going to walk home
odom is on the move
he ends up at third jp crawford an rbi
double ties the score at 1-1 here in the
third
and that gets away and that'll bring
home odom jp to third
wild pitch
mariners have the lead
and hard that is a fair ball
down into the corner jp scores tony kemp
gets it back in seeger will hold it
third and rbi double tie france and the
mariner league goes to three to one here
in the third inning
fly ball a little dunk shot that'll work
seeger scores
four to one mariners
tim lopes with an rbi single they keep
the line moving and bob melvin's seen
enough
put in play diving stop
dropped everybody's safe another run
scores it's 5-1 mariners
lamb could not come up with the handle
up the middle base hit
[Applause]
how to get a couple more in
as lopes and white score and the
mariners having a party here it's 8-1 in
the third
a lot of real estate who's going to get
it seeger calls off and make that france
fine play one out
ty had to cover some ground
see him playing towards the middle of
the diamond
all kinds of room in
oakland good job good communication
minnesota twins toward the gap nobody's
going to get it it's going to go to the
wall
here comes canada toward third he's
going to be held up as mamaleo's
got to the ball quickly so second and
third one out
[Applause]
that one smoked to right field and it
looked like lopes couldn't see it it
drops in front of him
so cannon will trot in the score
and there's a sun field out there
crawford france lopes
white
bishop and strange gordon
there's sager driving one deep to right
and gone
he has really heated up this last week
to 10 days two run homer in the first
game and he's got a lead off blast here
in the fourth to make it 9-2 mariners
and congratulations to kyle seeger 500
extra base hits in his career
another long one to right lopes at the
wall and that baby's gone grossman with
a two-homer game
oh he's got eight homers out of here
first
straight away center fielded deep
loriento giving up on that one saying
goodbye
home run evan white 10-3 mariners boy he
hit the daylights out of that ball his
eighth home run another rbi for him here
in this game
on the field again bloke city it's going
to work dee's going to score easily 11-3
mariners as we play here in the fifth
inning oops rbi single third inning
high five ball deep carry left field
tony kemp watch as he get out
home run tim lopes
second homer of the season second rbi
today second hit today the mayor's lead
is 12-3
bobby grossman
[Applause]
three hits two homers in a single for
robbie grossman so a bright spot today
[Applause]
double play
and this boys and girls is a done deal
justin dunn wins his fourth game
mariner's resounding triumph 12-3 they
sweep their
only double header this season jp
crawford hot bat among others mike yeah
it's a good way for sheffield and done
both to finish up their year they both
had to work hard today